des deux agriculteurs convoqué au
tribunal
nous n'enverrons qu'un l'autre considéré
comme plus rugueux de caractère a été
présenté avec les menottes
tous les deux sont accusés de
maltraitance sur animaux dans cette
petite commune de 180 habitants à la
frontière entre l'ain et le jura
une situation sanitaire apocalyptique
selon les voisins consterné par la
détresse des 350 bovins qui ont dû être
évacuées on peut pas être insensible
quand on voit des animaux boîtier est en
mauvais état donc c'est qu'il ya
forcément des problèmes des dizaines et
des dizaines de bovins qui crèvent
parenti on savait qu'ils n'allaient en
moyenne 80 parents ses amis pour la
profession agricole
hamon fleurs tout le monde subissait les
errements du troupeau affamés et livré à
lui même un moment donné on s'était dit
c'est comme ces commandes sont sacrés
le maire du village a alerté de
nombreuses fois les pouvoirs publics
sans résultat quant aux gendarmes ils
avaient un abonnement à mon fleurs une
centaine d'interventions rien que l'an
dernier
le fait qu'ils aient jamais de vraies
sanctions vis-à-vis de cet homme il
s'est dit et il me l'a dit ouvertement
il m'a dit de tout ça sans vous ne
pourrez rien contre moi j'ai la
préfecture avec moi j'ai l'injustice
avec moi qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
hier une cinquantaine de gendarmes
plusieurs vétérinaires ont été
réquisitionnés pour vider l'exploitation
une opération inédite en france quant
aux deux frères il ne voyait plus le
bout du tunnel
on leur a retiré l'agrément aoc pour le
compte et donc ça fait plonger un petit
peu les finances de la ferme
et puis l'accident du travail pour l'un
décès de la maman qui vivait encore avec
eux qui les aidaient bref des
circonstances une grande détresse
les deux agriculteurs risquent une
interdiction totale d'exploiter des
animaux d'élevage et une amende de 100
mille euros